for his defense did you hear this Brett
Kavanaugh submitted into evidence his
summer of 1982 calendar that's a real
thing he submitted his 1982 calendar so
far the only thing that proves about
Kavanagh is he's a weird freak who keeps
calendars from 1982 and he'll who needed
a calendar in high school I don't know
you go to school you come yeah mine said
get beat up go home get beat up go home
then dad beats me up
Oh he'd like to try yeah my dad used
that bass to go at it all the time oh
yeah he's a scientist
anyway that's crazy he Brady had kept
his calendar yeah yeah in Brett
Cavanaugh's 1982 high school calendar
true story
he mentioned seeing movies like Rocky 3
and grease - yeah I think this hurts his
credibility because what idiot would
leave hard evidence that they saw grease
- who would record that I don't know for
all of time I have no idea yeah I burned
my all my papers concerning grease to
have been destroyed long ago I don't
weigh me scrabble fans here but Scrabble
just added two new words to its
dictionary this is true two new words
okay and you okay and you have been
added to Scrabble yeah coincidentally
okay and you are the two words the
Senate will use when voting on Cavanaugh
so sorry 21 to you
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you
it Trump spoke at the UN yesterday did
you see this and yeah he spoke at the UN
that was entertaining analyst analysts
say president Trump treated his UN
speech yesterday as if he was at one of
his rallies that's how he behaved at the
UN and he behaved the same way he does
at his rallies yeah Trump said his
favorite part was getting the crowd to
chant lock her up in 17 different
languages it's really fun people
people didn't know what they were saying
yeah
interesting news president Trump did you
know this he has a brand new
technologically upgraded presidential
limousine yes it's supposed to be very
fancy and the latest with all the
technology for Trump's protection the
limo comes with bulletproof windows and
no Twitter
oh yeah very good Tony yes
these twitter is a problem yes next
month First Lady Melania Trump is gonna
leave for a solo trip to Africa
yes title of the tour will be get me out
of this [ __ ] show
take off are you missing something I'm a
big fan of scientific advances in the
field of medicine because you know I'd
like to stay here as long as possible
well anyway scientists announced they've
just developed a robotic caterpillar
that can crawl inside you for medical
procedures is that amazing yeah and for
an extra 50 bucks for non-medical
here you go thank you and then it leaves
me why did I act it all out there's no
reason no idea no reason you paid for
the mind classes you might as well you
might as well you carry on
you